[Music]
in an industrial mixer a worker pours
gelatin capsules over potassium chlorate
gelatin serves as a binder for the
match-head compound the worker adds hot
water before he starts the mixer to
dissolve the gelatin which combines
itself with a potassium powder the
worker then adds silica granules which
act as a combustion controlling agent he
rinses the sides of the mixer with water
as the compound mixture reduces after
about 40 minutes when the mixture is
liquid the worker adds red coloring as
well as other compounds that make the
match head burn more vigorously on the
splint production line a worker inspects
a batch of splintered aspen wood
impregnated with ammonium phosphate to
prevent afterglow the splints run over
perforated plates to shake off any
residue or waste then they go through a
machine which automatically discards
broken or undersized splints the splints
now reach the match dipping line where
the perforated steel match bar runs down
an endless chain the automatic feeder
inserts over 2 million splints per hour
into the sockets of the match bar the
splints first get a paraffin coating
while a mixer keeps the match-head
compound liquid the loaded match bar
lowers the splints to dip their heads in
after 5 seconds the match bar moves back
up and the head compound mixture flows
down into the mixing pan to be renewed
before another section of the match bar
moves in
after dipping the splints keep rolling
down the match bar chain for drying the
chain loops up and down for about 1 hour
leaving the match head compound time to
dry slowly and thoroughly once the heads
are dry the finished matches are ready
for packaging but first the filling
machine routes the outer and inner match
box liners onto parallel conveyors on a
high-speed line the machine can process
at least 500 boxes per minute the
finished matches finally come off the
match bar and the filling machine places
them into the inside liner at this point
the machine processes about 200 matches
per second the filling machine pushes
the inner liner to the outer skillet the
machine is calibrated to fill each box
with a set amount of matches and reject
the extra ones filled boxes come out on
a packaging conveyor you can find them
in small cartons medium sized packages
or heavy duty crates but it takes just a
single match to light your fire